uncle Joey here a man of many reefers
Tuesday November 29th swinging dick and
giving our chicken pox you understand me
you know what I missed you [__] I
really do what I don't see you for a few
days I get [__] teary-eyed and I'm
like what am I [__] savages don't you
understand it but [__] it's not what
you're doing or what you did
it's what the [__] you're gonna do
tonight it's a beautiful day to be alive
the birds are chirping you know and
you're swinging dick and taking [__]
names cuz that's the type of
[__] you are he's worried about
they say it isn't a recount
you know the holidays who gives a [__]
you gotta go out there and make it
happen however you can you know why
because you're associated with the man
of many reefers
it's a beautiful day today we got the
Skywalk I got a brand new dose of
[__] phantom og
we got a dose [__] brain freeze
understand me it's Tuesday you got to
pull out all the [__] stops no
jujitsu today I got Greg Fitzsimmons a
serious show I got a meeting at 1:00 I
got a podcast at 8:00 tonight with my
man Greg Proops the church and that's it
[__] just getting ready for [__]
Portland Oregon Oh
tremendous I love when we get together
in the morning for this little tape day
this isn't at all about anybody could
[__] him you know but to get together
with his [__] soldiers at 8:30 a.m.
smoking [__] reefer that people die
for him in California's [__] brain
freeze oh it smells like my fungi toes
shavings you understand me that's when
you know it's gonna be [__] good when
it's got that fungi to [__] and odor to
it feeling good looking good got a nice
night sleep I [__] went to jujitsu
yesterday went to the chiropractor wrote
with my man you know I'm just trying to
take care of everything baby boy you
have to you have to be on top but you
got to control your [__] game next
week December 8th see so TV my special
my first special up to 25 years yeah I'm
a [__] mutt but it's here and I need
you guys to [__] help me out with it
and get two months for free on seeso TV
just gonna see so TV called Joey and you
get two months for free and you can
watch my specials not gonna cost your
[__] time
bless you'd be helping uncle Joey I
understand I hope you are a lot of [__]
stuff do you feeling down I come on here
we smoked some [__] reefer I blow
smoke into the [__] screen things
happen understand me
look at who makes you happier than you
Uncle Joe walk around now you wanna hang
out with friends at Starbucks get the
[__] out of my face or these people
walking around Brandon it's Christmas
this that you don't give a [__] you're
coming out with your heart and [__]
today understanding testosterone is
[__] coming out of your ears because
you're a bad [__] you don't need
this aggravation there's a [__] about
recap
all they do is try to throw [__]
curveball say you don't worry about
nothing and put your [__] boots on
you get your Marine flag you salute the
[__] Flag you get your refund you get
out there and do what's best for you
brother
dad knew it's best for you nothing's
best for you for [__] little Harvey
Hall more friends that we love it when
you go down in protest an owl looks so
valiant of you get the [__] out of my
face you want to be valiant no
[__] hook and tell a pimp to
suck a dick that's valence right there
let's finish this [__] I walked since
we're here like family kaput
like then in the Garden of Good and
[__] evil
you got a guy at the box today like you
don't give a [__]
that's how I get out of the box
everything like I don't give a [__] I
don't give a [__] no more people I
haven't given a [__] for 20 [__]
years
someday you're gonna wake up and go
what's all this commotion
I got it bought this sling dick and look
after my back cuz when I go to the
supermarket and it comes time to [__]
lay out the Duckett's I'm the one who's
there that President Karzai president
Hillary none of these [__] four
friends of mine that we love you don't
love nobody
I'll get that I love reefer
that's it never lets me down I get nice
and baked I get to [__] around with you
savages and that said it's a whole new
set of rules people have repay the rule
[__] chain and they don't apply to
you no rules apply to you his balls you
gotta get up right your balls get out
there and let him know you're in the
[__] house and you ain't backing down
just once you back down you're lost
that's it you're lost
and that's it and that's that you know I
love you [__] without you guys
I'd have a box I did this [__]
everything I [__] got I'm saying but
uh I'll be in Portland Oregon I can't
[__] wait
roses dispensary I mean it's just a
[__] party up damn Portland
Thursday Friday Saturday and Gilead
Saturday night third Friday night I'm
gonna get some food truck action where
you go them we have two friends I don't
let you off the hook like that what
profession we'll see at the Church of
what's happening okay you want to have
the other buddies on different podcast
we got fizzled where's the [__] poof
where's the work where's the work
there's no work these people please
don't get me stun
we smoke anyway and I ate a clock
Greg Proops we're going deep tonight
Thursday to Portland Oregon and a week
from Thursday December 18 there's where
I need you [__] see so TV just
press and co Joey you get two months for
free I don't want a dime for the [__]
special I just want you to want it I
just want you to watch it and watch my
artwork whatever the [__] if you like it
whatever you don't what am I going to do
I can't cry over spilt milk and that's
it [__] I love you don't take
[__] from nobody today and tell them up
with Joey sent you showing up with two
big balls filled with yum-yum juice all
right that didn't get my metal up in
your room [__] antimatter for oppa I
love you [__] stay black I'll
see you tonight